Let me go! What are you doing?
Put a lid on it!
Nice place you got, kid.
Get out!
This is my house!
Oh, come off it.
Can't even protect a little girl...
-What do you say?
-He's got gold!
Sold her for money, huh?
No! I wouldn't do that!
You let them pay you off?
Sheeta told me to do it.
So...
So you gave in and crawled home.
You call yourself a man?
You talk big, but you're after Sheeta too.
But of course, we're pirates.
Pirates hunt for treasure.
Those guys are strange ones.
What's the girl to them?
You think she'll get out alive?
So, Sheeta told you to leave?
They threatened her,
so she tried to save you.
How do you know, Mama?
I've been a woman for 50 years.
She steels her heart
to save her man. How touching.
Reminds me of my youth.
If you boys want to get married,
look for one like her.
-So that girl will grow up...
-To be like Mama?
What a waste.